leute herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge ein tag persönlicher koch und ganz
kurz sofort los geht eine anekdote ihr
seht schon das video heute findet mit
kelly stadt aber ein versöhnlicher koch
war eigentlich nie als format geplant
sondern ich habe irgendwann habe gedacht
da warten wir also dessen tauschen
können stehen übrigens hiervon größer
aus
aber jetzt haben wir so essen tauschen
uns sowas getreten wird und ich dachte
wir unseren erich koch mal einen tag für
dich und dann hattest du irgendwie sagt
kuhr gemacht oder sowas und dann darf
man gut bei den anderen weil ich kann ja
schlecht dreimal sagt für dich und dann
habe ich mir für mich kann so mit dem
thema und deshalb existiert dieses mal
wirklich wieder nach oben gebracht hat
deshalb welchen heute bisschen mühe
geben und wir starten mit smash avocado
droht mit pochierten ei nun green
smoothie und einem cappuccino und let's
go ich hab's mehr stammlokal clubs sehr
ernst genommen bei kelly liebt backwaren
tod allen voran die acht und ihr wisst
ja vielleicht machen wir haben dort auch
schon mal zum beispiel lokale wo es gibt
eine deckung ein großer fan und die
machen handgemachtes brot ist wirklich
einfach die 50 mal dran
ich hätte das einzige was problematisch
ist natürlich keine zahnschmerzen gehabt
deshalb werde ich selbst wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so krass tiere essen können
bei gerade so ein knuspriges manager
bekommen nehmen wenn ich für dich kommen
kann bin ich ja auch verschiedene schon
vorgegeben
wir werden alles zusammen finden uns nur
wir brauchen eine banane wird ein wenig
ingwer das schon mal eine gute frische
aktiv geworden behandelt und ich bekenne
mich mit dem bild des spielers also wir
nehmen bald die gesamte berner oberland
ich hasse sie eigentlich aber ich liebe
es musik kann man auch gefroren dazu
dienen
noch heute wird er tief entspannen also
wir haben ein absolut ist finale heute
abend das lehrerbild auch richtig cool
heute mittag keinen schimmer verraten
wird wieder ein bisschen gebracht
gepackt sehr sehr lecker heute alles
irgendwie immer mit löffelchen berlin
es ist richtig die sieht kann mir aber
auch die zuschauer haben sich
richtigerweise dazu sank draufgehen
er sieht so einfach aus was du ja macht
sich ein topf mit wasser aufgesetzt wie
man danach passierte eier dazu wie man
das ganze mit avocado so wir werden eine
hälfte kam ganz keiner was vor sich geht
jetzt mal das brot zum anrösten einfach
straif auf das backblech jetzt extra
knusprig zudem das wasser aufgekocht ich
dessen temperatur ein bisschen runter
neben mir ein wenig essig hinein und
jetzt leute ich hab gehört also dass man
nicht unbedingt diesen strudel machen
muss sondern dass man die einfach so
rein gleiten da sind kann ich probiere
es einfach mal aus jasid solider aus
oder dann ist es auch schon soweit ich
hole mal aus dem ba co das angepasste
brot raus dann brauchen wir unsere
avocadocreme großes ziel ich darauf
verteilen
das hat überraschend gut funktioniert
ohne den strudel
wir haben hier fertig
[Musik]
endlich ist es soweit ist hier ein
pochiertes ei nem avocados sandwich café
greens mutig waren wir gerade habe ich
glaube ich auch mit ihm nächste
feuerwehr finde sowas einfach mit den
händen auf geprägt also mein mund ist so
richtig deutlich
okay wir sehen auf der jeder zur
bewertung auf den fall aufgegriffen
hatte knackige portionen megawatt sehr
lecker wirklich mal was du sagst waren
die eier damit fragt es ja mit was
wichtig sich heftig die waren sehr sehr
gut ich fand das verbot hat ein bisschen
noch vollgas bisschen zu oft aber das
brot wahrheit sondern qualität so
hässlich gut das ist fast gar nicht böse
sein kann der charakter müssen würde
dazu sagen weil ich auch so
seit wochen sind ganz vielen cafés in
köln machen nochmal so richtig gute
maschinen und ich muss sagen ich bin
aber auch dass sich um sehr gute kaffee
getrunken das scheint diese das wollen
der ski war ein bisschen klumpp alles
wirkt eher jahren wollten
ich habe sie alle sind ja acht von zehn
und werden
ich finde das ist so ein hübsches
schnelles frühstück teams hoffen aber
auf jeden fall profitieren kunden
überhaupt nicht erzählt und wir sehen
uns jetzt zum mittagessen getroffen weil
man erzählerin nicht entschieden was
freunde kommen auch zum mittagessen ich
habe bereits den ofen vorgeheizt und
eine rührschüssel hingestellt es wird ja
einfach was wir machen es wird auch sehr
lecker ist es mal wieder ein cheesecake
bzw
nein kommt jetzt der moment meines
ersten cheese cake käsekuchen die ok
keks teigboden cremige soße käsekuchen
die aversion post im ultra lecker wir
machen das ganze wir brauchen und das
kein spaß
zwei von diesen xxl packung frischkäse
sind 660 gramm und 250 gramm mascarpone
creme täglich immer zu greifen also
werden wir haben jetzt auch die 900.000
autos erreicht bin mega happy darüber
es hat natürlich gezogen auch mit
zahnschmerzen also frisch wie sie in die
rührschüssel dann als nächstes unsere
mascarpone komplette packung und dann
schmeißt sich das ganze mal zuerst auf
niedriger stufe karl hätten wir hier
eine backform immer mal so von der seite
unterschieden damit auch wirklich an
dabei ist dann benötigen jetzt 300 gramm
zucker
ich weiß es ist ein wenige und dazu
geben jetzt nach und nach dazu
und dann können wir auch ein bisschen
höher gehen mit der stufe von generation
wie ihr sehen können ist das ganze sehr
schön cremig gerührt jetzt also wirklich
top jetzt gehen wir nach und nach sechs
eier dazu wenn das alles klinik ist
gehen wir doch ein letztes geld dazu
dann kommt dazu eigentlich diese seite
also 34 34 100 milliliter sahne
man merkt schon dass wird deutlich
flüssiger als in new york schloss beck
dann zwei teelöffel vanille extrakt und
ein teelöffel orangen extra dann mach
mit auch soll das wirklich eine ganze
menge die wird ja dazu sieben wir 60
gramm also das können wir mit unter und
dann sind wir auch schon fertig und dann
fangen wir uns zwei backpapier und
der formel 1 stand so richtig schön
engen sein und dann nochmal auf die
falsche seite 12
dann läuft jetzt wirklich alles gut
untergemischt ich war mir die schlüssel
und wir schicken das ganze einfach in
die mitte reform auf jeden fall jede
menge in den ofen überfallen und so
läuft das ganze für eine stunde der ist
wirklich krass hochgesand fehlt aber
noch ein ganzes stück ein und wir lassen
einfach die tür offen stehen dann fällt
der kuchen bei zimmertemperatur ein und
wir können gleich essen nicht aus aber
genau das wollte ich also dafür so
leicht verbund ist es ist drei tage drei
negative kroner test und einen toten
zahn später es war wirklich nicht mehr
auswahl und ich musste abbrechen
die erste folge persönlicher kocht die
ich ausnahme ist habe ich mich im herzen
weh getan dann auch noch als wir die
900.000 mussten kaká denn wir ziehen das
ganze natürlich durch kelly
du hast und keinen kuchen den regen
sofort und ja noch ein leckeres
abendessen deshalb bringen wollen
[Musik]
das ist der clou darf es gerne probieren
aber wieder ja hallo ich bin sehr
gespannt wie die erste kabel und damit
die kameradschaft schon wieder geöffnet
die käsekuchen kritikerin ja das bin ich
ja alles schon sehr viele käsekuchen
leben gegessen ist gab es sehr viele
verschiedene käsekuchen
deswegen war ich sehr gespannt welche
nur auserwählten wirst ich habe die
konsistenz sehr lecker gewiss sehr
luftig das gefällt mir sehr ich mache es
auch dass keinerlei im boden und war
weil keiner hat bock auf boden seiner
man kann nicht jeder will nur diese
käsekuchen füllung die und auf möglichst
der ressourcen künftig außerdem ist es
leicht den mandarinen orangen nicht zu
viel nicht zu wenig und man komme dann
trotzdem noch dieses grobe von diesem
quadranten dazu
deswegen muss ich an dieser stelle sagen
ich hätte es nicht besser machen können
ich bräuchte auch nirgendwo besser
glaube ich 19 war es ja machen sich gar
nicht wirklich eigentlich alle meine
pferde auf das aber jetzt http t.co oder
deaktiviert da bin ich mir ist alles
wir sehen uns zum abendessen kommen wir
auch zu machen ersten leute kelly hat
sich von mir etwas besonderes gewünscht
die vorher war ein schönes der dazu eine
kurze also so ein amerikanischen
krautsalat und es war irgendwo trüffel
mit drin sein und wollen ihr wisst es
für meine gäste nur das beste ich habe
ja ein amerikanisches jahresrekord das
werde ich jetzt halbieren
das sind nämlich zwei steaks waren und
dann ist solid jahren also im wasserbad
und das stelle ich auf 54 grad ein
das ist medium rare dann wird das
fleisch kommt natürlich jetzt auf 54
grad und damit packe ich auch die 300
grad heiße gusseisernen platten sagt
spricht das ist die sicherste weise sehr
sehr gutes recht zu machen hat auf jeden
fall was gut ist dass ich den dreh
abbrechen musste weil jetzt ist das
wetter draußen so perfekt dass kenteris
vorschnell und ich kann jetzt auch mit
essen weil man es haben wieder hallt
durch die temperatur 54 grad gestellt
und ich halte das ganze jetzt für knapp
drei stunden durch anmachen und ihr seht
ihr da wird das wasser so zirkuliert ich
kann einfach die stakes dazu rein
gruppen in zirka einer stunde haben die
dann 44 grad durch erreicht und dann
kann ich jederzeit ausziehen und auf dem
grill fertigmachen sehr entspannt zu
unserem stayguest geprüftes kategorie
und chrysler geben
wir brauchen also cool denn sonst wäre
es nur einen slot kohl knoblauch
zitronen karten mario buttermilch gucken
dass alles was wir brauchen wir kann mit
100 gramm mai wird und große portion
keine sorge dazu geben wir 60 gramm
butter milch ein wenig fein
geschnittenen schnittlauch und das ging
jetzt alles zusammen in eine baumreihe
bereit eine knoblauchzehe eine besonders
schön
ich habe so meine finger wahlrecht rege
benutzt hat dann brauchen wir die schale
und den saft von 1 zitrone so die reihe
ist groß und so zwei karotten kommen
hier hinein und das gleiche meinen armen
werden dann wieder machen wir doch mit
zwei sekunden
hier schneidet das ist einfach immer
sehr unappetitlich für mich so was auch
weil ich nicht so groß in dem wir jetzt
mal so vier stück wirken auch dazu und
jetzt fehlt auch eine zutat die
hauptzutat raketen diesen kohl den
erbärmlichen gewähren ihnen jetzt
verlieren wir brauchen einen halben kopf
und dann schleichen einfach ganz breit
es gibt auf jeden fall ordentlich
kursana ich hoffe das ist in ordnung für
dich dann sind wir zu fast wert wie man
noch das kartoffelgerichte wir schneiden
jetzt die kartoffeln in gleichgroße
stücke sondern wenn das wasser kocht
geben wenig offen bleiben und kochen sie
so für 15 20 minuten bis sie weich sind
und wann werden sie gestampft haben mich
auf jeden fall ich habe nämlich mein
kartoffelstampf verlegt und ich muss das
jetzt irgendwie anderweitig machen und
butter dazu und ein wenig muskeln so es
ist jetzt soweit guckt euch das an ist
es komplett durchgegart das sieht
erstmal befremdlich aus das kriegt den
stage erst gleich wenn wir es an brachen
deshalb hole ich ihm auspackt auf den
teller und dann gehen die linke hier
sind also unsere stakes liegt von ultra
kam und jetzt bleibt uns nur noch übrig
sie zu tradieren schöne scheiben zu
schneiden und zu dem wir sie dann auf
den teller
[Musik]
endlich ist es soweit heute das erste
mal dass ich mich auch unternehmen mit
krediten
geil es sieht einfach mit keiner außer
stiegen bei zehn zählern aber irgendwann
werde holen dann so viel verraten dass
das sehr schön sehr gut aus da stehen
wir vor einem leeren teller kommen wir
zu bewerten ob es ihm geschmeckt mega
ich bin noch mehr fertig und vor allem
kohls vorabend jordan gehabt ein
bisschen drüber geredet die zitronen
drohte war sehr endlich hatte war gar
nicht stört
kannst du das sehr erfrischend und da
kommen wie der kartoffelbrei
ausgestanzten löschen hören war
natürlich immer ein paar absolut
grandios tut sich an dieser stelle sagt
und ist denn eigentlich gar nicht sein
also mit diesem jahr den dann noch auf
den betten gerade haben wir glaube ich
keiner guckt
deswegen muss ich dir auch hier wieder
seine 95 thesen einfach geil wirklich
top bewertung heute eingefangen ich bin
ich happy das war echt cool dass hier
was das ist
der dreht habe ich habe hier einen
erwähnt und das war's von video wir
sehen uns spätestens nächsten sonntag
wieder und danke dass ihr so geduldig
wird und momentan geht jetzt besser
tisch